in Miami at a shopping mall a a giant
creature either an alien or one of the
Nephilim or I I guess it could be
something else Bigfoot or just a you
know really tall hairy guy or anyway
something was there and there were a lot
of cops allegedly and a bunch of people
ran out screaming and so to help us
analyze this really really important
story uh we bring on daily wire's Chief
alien corresp respondent Matt Walsh Matt
can you take us through What's Happening
Here uh yeah well it's uh just like you
I woke this morning and I saw two things
uh trending on Twitter I saw uh I saw uh
aliens and I saw Miami Mall were the two
things that were trending and so I
immediately knew that there are aliens
at a Miami mall and that is exactly what
has happened so
apparently well there's there's as
always you know there's the official
story and that would really happen MH so
the official story is that there was
some sort of fight at this mall in Miami
and a bunch of cops showed up uh to
break up the fight now when I heard that
I said to myself that that can't a fight
at a mall never it's never happened that
in Miami of all places are you kidding
me and so I said that's that that's not
no something's wrong here uh and then I
dug a little bit deeper and I found that
no there are these stories of about
aliens now the the corporate
media uh the lib media is not reporting
on the alien aspect at all you have to
what you have to do is you have to go to
the journalist on Tik Tok MH which I
don't know if you've done done Michael
but I but I've uh spent a lot of time
this morning fact I was supposed to be
prep I was supposed to be prepping for
my own show and I most of the time I was
just watching Tik Tok videos about these
aliens and and what they're what they're
claiming is it was not just one but it
was in fact a group of uh aliens between
eight and 10 feet tall that were at this
mall and um and then people
fled and uh and they and I don't the
aliens could still be at the mall right
now I don't know where they are at the
moment but but so we know not to trust
the lam Stream Drive by corporate media
they're they're not going to give us the
truth we all know that uh obviously
people on Twitter with lots of esoteric
uh names and and numbers in their in
their uh accounts with like three to 20
followers are certainly much more
trustworthy uh do we have any idea what
the aliens were doing at the
mall uh I don't think we know for sure
but I think it's not hard to imagine
what they might be doing I know a lot of
people were skeptical uh about this
because they said well you came all this
way and the first thing you do is you
stop at a mall in Miami but I can I can
absolutely see why I mean if you think
about it I don't know where they came
from but they've probably been in the
spaceship for for I mean like thousands
of years and so they land the spaceship
and they're like well they got to
stretch their legs first of all and they
probably they needed to get some
supplies they probably they got to get
some toiletries I know I've been you
probably had the same thing where you go
on a long trip with your family and you
get to wherever you're going and as soon
as you park one of your kids is like I
forgot my jacket or you know I don't
have a shoe and so then what do you have
do to find what do you do you find a
mall and whatever place you went to uh
to buy and so it could be something like
that you know they buy a jacket I I
don't know I I also have heard and again
I'm not an astronomer or an astrologer
but I've heard that they don't have
Spencer gift shops on Mars or Planet
Zebula 14 so that they also might have
just wanted to go get a whoopy cushion
I'm sure it wasn't the the most humorous
you know Journey o over many many light
years so they probably wanted to just
buy a little gag you know have some fun
spook out some people is there any
chance that there is a more I don't know
logical or likely explanation for this
like that they're not you know
extraterrestrial aliens but that the the
shadowy figures on the uh footage were
the Nephilim instead
no there's there's literally no other
explanation that I could possibly think
of you know I I
uh one of the one of the Tik Tok videos
that I that I watched was a man that was
reporting anyway at the time that he
actually was an eyewitness of this and
he said that he came out of a Foot
Locker and people were running and and
he looked behind him briefly and saw
these shadowy figures that were coming
after him but he said something very
interesting I'm just quoting him here
but he actually said that when he looked
he saw uh quote quote unquote fat chicks
running and uh and my my point was was
like well why would fat chicks be
running it's not something they
typically do and um you know there could
have been maybe they're giving free
samples out at Cinnabon or something but
I but I think that it's like it could be
that or more more like the scenarios
that it was it was aliens or CH now I
will say that particular guy then did
another video where he said that the
last video was a hoax and that he was
joking but um that just tells me that
they got to him and it does right now go
to goodranchers.com use code nlls you
know what I had for dinner was it two
nights ago I had a beautiful delicious
good ranchers chicken and I usually I'm
more of the good ranchers steak eye but
the chicken is also it's just the best
stuff out there put some prep in your
step with good ranchers in this new year
it's a new year new meat special
delicious safe and convenient meal prep
is just one box away 2024 is your year
to ditch the mystery of the meat Isis
get American Meat delivered right to
your door instead when you subscribe to
any box of good ranchers they will add
over 2 lbs of pre-trimmed better than
organic chicken breasts to your order
for free not once not twice but every
order for a year I just adore it it's
the highest quality stuff out there the
prices are unbelievably low I asked the
founder and CEO the other day I said how
are you doing this he said well my CFO
doesn't like it but you know anyway the
business is growing a lot as well it
should it sign up right now go to
goodranchers.com use code NES kW to
enjoy free chicken in 2024 plus an
additional 20 bucks off off your first
order if you want to start off your year
right then change the way you buy meat
by switching to good ranchers subscribe
today use code nolles to claim over 200
bucks in free chicken and New Year
savings goodranchers.com American Meat
delivered look I saw the most important
video the one that has gone viral and
that continues to be trending even right
now and it's the video where they say
here you can see the giant 10ft tall
dark shadowy figure and I will admit to
you Matt I as I looked at it
I I don't really know what they're
talking about cuz I can't I just see
like a light like a kind of very
pixelated light oh come on no you can
see you no you see a there's a smudge
it's like a smudgy it's a smudge yeah
there's a smudgy well it's first of all
well look we admit it was it was a
lowquality the guy whoever took the film
he had the first camera phone that's
ever been made he still had he pulled it
out of his drawer I wish I wish he had
used even like an iPhone 7 or something
something more recent mhm noia or a
Polaroid perhaps anything would but
that's what he used and you can see a
smudgy uh figure walking and then you
you keep in mind what some of the
eyewitnesses have said that it's a the
aliens are shadowy and so it all kind of
makes sense this is why when you see
aliens on film they're always uh blurry
it's because the aliens themselves are
literally they're blur they're blurry
figures yes exactly that that makes
sense some have suggested Matt that
these kinds of stories making the rounds
are are nothing more than a distraction
from stories that actually involve
political corruption say at the very
Heights of power you know uh like I
don't know to use a conspiracy theory
like the notion that the wealthiest
richest most influential and famous
people in the world would all go to a
secret pedophile island in the Caribbean
and they were all caught on camera doing
very criminal acts and it was covered up
by the intelligence agencies around the
world and you know blah blah blah
conspiracy theories whatever just to
entertain the notion do you think
there's anything to that no I don't
think so I don't think there's any
there's nothing to any theory that
doesn't end in Aliens first of all
that's my that's a general principle
that's a rule of thumb that I think hit
you far in life but also uh the in all
seriousness not that I'm not being
serious already it the idea that this is
that any of this stuff is a distraction
doesn't work because it's not a
distraction no one like nobody cares at
all no one cares about what we're
talking about right now everyone's
already turned off everyone has turned
us off no one is listening anymore I'm
shock they were listening in the first
place exactly so if they were listening
at all they aren't listening anymore
because nobody for people should don't
be wrong people should care about the
alien stuff but I know from experience
it pains me deeply that nobody does so
anytime I hear this stuff about oh this
is the powers that be trying to distract
us they would there are so many ways to
distract us um that they don't need to
resort to aliens and also the aliens for
some reason are the least distracting
they want to distract us just they could
something about Taylor Swift like
attending a Kansas City Chiefs game is
far more absorbing to people than aliens
are um so that's actually the strongest
argument I've heard so far that the
alien thing isn't just a total scop is
you're right they could just they could
point to you know the latest lunch that
Kim Kardashian had and everyone would
turn their heads that way as well uh
have you noticed
there are some prominent conservatives
of late who have suggested that uh
perhaps the aliens there's a what we're
calling the UFOs they might actually be
part of a more of a spiritual
conversation and that maybe certain
people in the do aliens exist or not
debate who have suggested that they're
more likely demons might be correct have
you come across any of that
commentary like the commentary that you
yourself have made many and and others
have I come across your own comment I
have I have come across that commentary
when you've said it to me yeah directly
I come across it then and I reject I
just it doesn't even make any what I
don't understand the theory obviously we
know that demons are real but they're
they're flying through the sky randomly
and then the powers of the air well hold
on I understand why aliens would be
flying through the sky I don't
understand
why demon and they're picked up on radar
and that sort of thing yeah why why what
all right we got to go man what a great
clip that was now hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nolles YouTube
channel see you next time